[Music]
Jessica it's so nice to have you here
with us today thank you it's nice being
here so you're one of the top tennis
players in the world but you're also
have a reputation as a bit of a late
bloomer so yeah four years ago when you
were ranked outside the top 100 did you
ever think you'd be where you are today
um uh probably not to be honest I mean I
always thought that I would make it
happen but at the same time putting in
all the work and then looking back four
years later about where my mindset was I
don't know if I really truly believed it
so um yeah it's I I did but I didn't I
don't know it's it's just been a very
long journey I guess when did that start
to change for you did you have a moment
where you thought oh yeah I can do this
yeah I would say when I kind of had my
breakthrough at Australian Open I don't
know 3 four years ago um you know going
deep in a grand slam was something I'd
never done and then it seems like since
then I've been able to go deep in every
tournament basically that I played and I
think that moment was definitely um a
breakthrough for me to realize that I
could play at the at the top level so
not that long ago you were playing at
these small tournaments on the ITF
circuit now you're one of the top seeds
at the world's biggest tournaments how
is life different for you you know as a
low ranked player versus one of the top
stars on tour yeah I mean I have way
more commitments a lot more
responsibilities uh especially at bigger
events especially tournaments you know
in the US where there's a lot of lot
more attention on American players um
you know the grand slams now that I'm
you know a top five seed and I think
I've gotten used to that over maybe the
past couple years um but it's been a
hard act to kind of balance you know all
the responsibilities that I have from
before when it was just you showed up in
practice now there's a lot more
commitments a lot more time a lot more
energy spent but um I think I just look
at it as you know part of my career and
my job to help grow the game as well
what what changed about your game to
help get you to this point was it more
physical or mental that that development
I would say both they probably went hand
inand like physically I got so much
stronger so much fitter a lot healthier
and then I think mentally that kind of
helped my mental game knowing that I
could you know last longer out there I
could play long matches I could play
matches back to back and not have to
worry about being tired or getting hurt
or something like that so um to me it
went hand inand I would say physically
probably First Once I felt better then
the mental game kind of followed along
with that for a long time you had this
goal to get into the top 100 and then it
was the top 50 and the top 30 and the
top 10 is is doing that kind of
incremental goal setting difficult I
think um I think having well I think
those were all small goals but also big
goals I I liked having goals to help
make me feel like I was making progress
but then beyond that there's a lot
smaller goals just like day-to-day goals
which I think helped me accomplish the
bigger goals and um to me it was always
fun it was always just like kind of a a
mental game you know try to improve
small little things and then reach the
bigger goals like top 100 top 50 and
they slowly just kind of came along long
and I don't think I used it as a way to
put pressure on myself it was more just
like a mind game that me and my coach
would play like oh gosh I'm you know if
I just get this many points I'll I'll be
top 20 uh you know small stuff like that
um it wasn't the focus but it was more
of just like a fun reward you had a lot
of success and a lot of consistent
success but I know one goal that's still
out there for you is having that
breakthrough at a major is is that
something that weighs on you or are you
able to sort of keep your focus on on
the positives I mean to I've had you
know already a lot of lot more success
at slams than I thought I would I mean
before I was just trying to win one
round at a slam and now it's you know
the goal is getting Beyond to semis
finals or winning a slam and I came
really close at wion this year and
eventually lost in the quarters to the
eventual Champion so I know that I'm
right there and I think with the women's
game there's so much depth that anybody
can kind of break through at any second
so that also gives me confidence you
know that it could happen any week um
but yeah I mean I wouldn't say it weighs
on me it's just something that you know
was yet to be accomplished and hopefully
I can get there so earlier in your
career you dealt with a couple of
serious injuries that sidelined you for
for pretty long stretches what kept you
going through what must have been
difficult rehabs
there uh there was definitely moments
where I didn't I didn't know how he was
going to get through some of the rehab
it can be very monotonous and boring and
very hard but I think um I think it was
just like my love for the game would
always kind of come through and I would
have these tough weeks in rehab and I
would see to always be able to get
through them or bounce back and um I
think I just wanted to get healthy and
give myself a chance to really prove you
know what I could do and not for other
people but I think more just for myself
and I you know knew I was right there I
practice you know practice with a lot of
the same girls and you see them watching
them on TV having great results and
you're sitting there injured and hurt
and I think that always kind of
motivated motivated me as well to to
give myself a chance to to come back and
be stronger and see what I could do so I
think that was a big motivation and then
just the passion you know that I love to
play the sport always kept me going and
um I think that's important it gets
tough if you don't love the sport so I
think that's what always kind of got me
coming back what do you love about
tennis I don't know it's just I love the
individuality of it I love that it's all
on you and I take a lot of pride in
knowing that not a lot of sports are
like that so to me it's really fun to be
able to say you know I'm an individual
athlete no I I don't I can't really talk
to my coach I can't really talk strategy
you know in really tough moments it's
you and I think that's what makes tennis
so unique and special so I've always
just I think taken pride in being able
to be that specific kind of athlete and
uh I think that's what I've just loved
most about it I mean it sucks when you
lose CU it's all on you but when you win
you know you're the one that got
yourself through a really tough moment
or a tough match and that to me is like
the best feeling you have a dry sense of
humor you're a little bit understated
you're not one of these sometimes you're
not one of these players though who's
you know screaming on the court or
smashing or Racket and I think sometimes
people see that and they maybe assume
that you aren't intense but clearly you
know it takes a determination to get to
where you are so how would you describe
your personality I'm very laid-back very
not a lot bothers me I don't get super
stressed out not super anxious I mean I
I definitely still have those feelings
of course like anybody else but I think
I'm I don't know I always just find a
way to get through it and I think that's
what people have kind of started to see
but that wasn't always easy for me at
the beginning of my career when I was
younger um you know like people will
comment a lot of my attitude that it
doesn't look like I want to be there and
it doesn't look like this so it was hard
for me to find like my identity on the
court but I think as I you know matured
got healthier you know mentally got a
lot tougher now people you know tell me
that they really appreciate my um calm
demeanor on the court which I think is
the biggest biggest accomplishment
considering what people used to say
about my attitude on the court so it's
really funny but yeah I'm just very calm
type of person I don't really get super
stressed out very very easily so over
the years I think pundits would
sometimes maybe say like oh she's hit
her ceiling and then you would smash
right through that so when you hear that
kind of discourse is that motivating or
is that frustrating um definitely I may
a little bit of both but I think more
motivating than anything um you know
it's easy for everyone to kind of just
sit there and make comments but I think
when you're the one putting in the work
you definitely use it as motivation all
the time um to try and get better but
also you can't always take what everyone
says into account I think if you start
thinking about what everyone else is
saying about you it can kind of have a
negative effect so I try my best to just
use it as motivation to keep getting
better and um you know in my mind if I'm
getting better then maybe those opinions
will change but I think yeah I think
I've proved that I've you know improved
a lot over the last few years and I
think broken most of the ceilings that
that people have thought about me so I
think it's nice looking back and knowing
I proved him wrong but at the same time
yeah you can't always you know take
everyone's opinion and try and you know
change it sometimes it's just how it is
but uh yeah I hopefully I can keep you
know breaking more of those opinions do
do you feel like you have another level
to get to definitely I think so I um I
think I've proved that the last few
years every single year it keeps seems
to be getting better and I know there's
always going to be challenges or maybe
that's not the case but you know in
tennis I think you can always improve
and I think I've already done that the
last few years so why not keep improving
the next few years and I think I can
definitely get there you're coming into
your own at this interesting time with
Serena Williams retired and a bunch of
young American players on the rise do
you feel there's an opportunity there
for you um definitely I think there's a
lot of opportunity for everyone really I
mean we saw Coco golf take advantage of
that at the US Open um really get hot
this summer and and prove that you know
she could be a slam Champion so I think
that definitely motivates me as well um
I think there's a lot of opportunity
right now for a lot of girls so me being
one of them so hopefully I can you know
take advantage of that but uh yeah it's
interesting with Serena being out you
know yeah I guess it's different it
feels more open even when she wasn't
playing full-time it was still like she
was always the favorite and now it's it
seems like a different time even though
we've already seen who the top players
are but um it's an opportunity for for
everyone so I think uh you know why not
me so I know there must be a lot of
pressure stepping into Serena shoes as
one of the top Americans but that's got
to be really validating too right yeah I
mean I don't think anyone can fill
Serena shoes uh having other top
Americans there definitely helps cuz I
couldn't imagine being the only American
um someone like you know someone like
Coco at least has a lot of pressure on
her as far as being I think regarded as
the next Serena or Venus so I don't
really see that as being a role I have
to fill but uh it's pretty cool when you
get to see records like I can say you
know I've won this many hardcore matches
hasn't been done since Serena or having
little stats like that is really cool
and um being able to to do it with Coco
as well who were 10 years apart in age
difference and you know we see stats
like that well you know two Americans
haven't been in the semis or the both
singles and doubles since Serena and
Venus like that's really really cool and
something I don't think I ever expected
to see but it's been nice to you know
see some statistics mixed in with my
name I don't think I'll ever definitely
not going to break the Grand Slam record
but it's pretty cool to to be mentioned
in that especially in American tennis
you mentioned Koko who's also your
doubles partner um what's your
relationship with like with her like um
being on a team do you do you um you
know you you have to be in the same
singles draws as her is there any
friendly rivalry what's what's that
relationship right I mean I think it's
cool that I was like the only one to
beat her this summer before she won the
US Open um but no we're very friendly
about it I mean I think we've learned a
lot from each other from playing doubles
um and we have a lot of fun playing
doubles even if we have to play singles
I mean it's not that big of a deal where
I think used to it and I think most
girls are are used to sometimes having
to play you know singles against your
doubles partner and I think it's more
just been a really fun Journey that that
both of us have been on at different
points of our career totally different
yeah totally different learning curves
you know she's learn learned done all
this so young and me being a late
bloomer it's very different but I think
we've gotten to learn from each other at
the same time and uh it's been really
cool to see what she's done and um yeah
we have a a good relationship on and off
the court I think it's we're compet
obviously very competitive but at the
same time I think learn a lot from each
other which is nice call out that age
difference you know you're you're under
30 and she's a full 10 years younger
than you is crazy is there any
generational friction between you do you
do you well I mean she definitely makes
me feel like she's definitely jenzy like
I can I I didn't really notice it and
then yeah as we start hanging out more
or just being together more you know on
tour I'm like okay yeah there's
definitely a generational Gap here uh no
friction but it's funny you know like I
don't know she makes fun of me CU I
don't know about any of the Tik Tok
Trends and stuff like that but um yeah
it's more just you know poking fun at
each other do you take any special pride
in being part of this All-American
doubles team with Coco oh yeah
definitely I mean it's really cool um
hopefully we can play Olympics next year
and I know that's a goal that she really
wanted to to try and get a medal there
and I think for me too um so yeah I mean
I think it's it's awesome I think it's
bringing a lot more fans to doubles I
think you know the fans really enjoy
watching us and even at the US Open this
year I mean we wouldn't play on a major
Stadium but um or on Arthur Ash per se
but we've played in a lot of the other
stadiums and it's packed for people to
come watch us play and to watch us play
singles and doubles I think that's great
for American tennis and it's been you
know really cool to see everyone so
interested in not just our singles but
us as a team you had this a bit of
unusual upbringing your parents own the
Buffalo Bills and the Buffalo Savers and
I know over the years people have maybe
questioned whether someone with that
kind of background can have you know the
fire to really succeed as a a pro tennis
player what are your thoughts on on that
I think that everyone who knows sports
or is an athlete or is highly
competitive or made it very far I think
knows that you're not really going to
get there unless you you know work hard
and you know are talented and really are
driven to to get there it's really
difficult so to me I think I've I mean
people say that but I think everyone
that knows kind of knows it's not going
to happen unless someone's really
a hard worker and driven so I don't
really worry too much about it I think
most people get that maybe some people
that I don't know just don't want to
like me for whatever reason maybe we'll
always say that but I can't really
change their mind but I've worked really
hard and um yeah I definitely wouldn't
have gotten here if it wasn't for that
do you have any thoughts yet on going
into the family business after you
retire from tennis I would love to stay
in sports but um yeah we'll see I feel
like it's still a little ways away but I
I do love sports so much and I would
love to stay in that sector and at some
point throughout you know my career
after tennis I think it would be really
awesome and I think I just have such a
connection and very grateful for being
able to to play at such a high level so
I would hope that would you know some of
that experience would take me into the
next phase of my career but we'll see
but yeah I would love to stay in sports
so you you grew up in Buffalo which is
not exactly a tennis hot spot so how did
you get into tennis why tennis so my
older sister played my older Half Sister
Laura played collegiately at the
University of Pittsburgh and so when I
was younger um I just started you know
taking lessons after school and I guess
I was pretty good for how young I was
and just kind of kept taking lessons and
saw some different coaches and I think
my parents just saw that I was talented
and wanted to see if you know where it
could go and then as I got older it was
a you know a goal to be professional be
number one in the world be all those
things and it kind of just yeah started
from there but I would say my my older
half sister played and that's kind of
how I got into it so off the court uh
you have a skincare business ready 24
that you founded a few years ago mhm was
starting a business something that had
always been on your mind um not really I
think it became one when I got hurt and
I was injured for a few of those years
um probably out for about almost 3 years
probably in total and I guess some
opportunities came to me and I start
thinking about well what if I'm not
going to play tennis I need to go back
to school I need to do all these things
and you know you start thinking about
about life without sports or tennis in
my case and that's when it kind of
became something I wanted to do and try
and the opportunity came for um with a
relationship with someone that I knew
from Buffalo New York and they helped me
guide me through the process really so
I've learned a lot from it and um yeah
it's been a while since I started it but
I've learned so much so hopefully you
know I can keep growing that how is the
company
growing it's hard I've learned it's hard
trying to do both especially when I'm
kind of just the one doing everything
but um you know as I I've kind of taken
a step back from it the last few years
because just playing and again reaching
a new ranking and having to to come into
all these new responsibilities and those
commitments has been challenging but
this year actually pre- US Open we
relaunched some new products so
hopefully the next couple years I really
really want to push especially on social
and especially now that people know me
more and they also bring up the fact oh
don't you have a skincare line and they
get really interested so I think seeing
that shift in you know myself as a brand
has also changed my perspective on that
and hopefully yeah the next few years I
can keep pushing it because it is
something I I really enjoy and I want to
be successful so I yeah hopefully we'll
we'll get there do you think of yourself
as a as a businesswoman has that become
part of your identity I think it has for
other people I don't really see myself
as a businesswoman but at the same time
I think I'm competitive and I want
things to be successful and I'm a little
bit of a perfectionist so I think I see
that those things more in me but um I
guess that could lead to a businesswoman
if someone would you know notice that
and I think yeah people usually tell me
that but uh to me I'm just competitive
and wanted to be successful that's what
I think of um also on the business side
of of the game you you have a few
traditional endorsements as well is that
is that something you enjoy working with
companies like that yeah of course I
think it's important you know to have
sponsors and people that enjoy working
with and you enjoy working with them and
I you know take a lot of pride in like
really being a great Ambassador for
whoever it is that I'm helping or
whoever sponsors me and treating them
well and yeah being professional about
it I think it's really important and
nowadays it's so important for an
athlete especially to have like a a
brand and be more than just the sport
and I think people really you know I
don't know find that interesting and I
think athletes are becoming more than
you know onedimensional becoming many
different things and showing their
interest on and off the field and I
think it's great cuz not everyone is
into sports everyone's into to different
things and yeah it's become something
that I yeah I take a lot of a lot of
pride in and I hope I can be a great
Ambassador for you know all the sponsors
that I have you you've kind of touched
on as as an athlete you have to you know
cultivate your own brand what's what's
that like for
you I think it's hard finding um well I
think you don't want to just take on
anything right you want to find things
that I think are genuine and you're
passionate about and I think that's the
difference where some people do some
people don't but at least what I find
different is finding athletes that truly
believe in something and I think when
you can fit that into your brand and uh
really cultivate that it's I think much
more special than just kind of taking
everything that's thrown your way so um
to me it's important to yeah have a
really big deep passion about what it is
and uh I think when you communicate that
to your to your fans and to to everyone
else it comes off so much more genuine
and I think much more authentic which I
appreciate especially nowadays in the
world of social media with all the
influencers I know stuff can feel kind
of fake so I think it's special when you
can do that you have a few sponsors is
that you know an area that you want to
expand or do you like having kind of a
slim portfolio that you can engage with
I mean I would always love to expand but
again expand with things that I actually
am genuinely passionate about I don't
want to just take things just because um
so hopefully yeah I would love to expand
as long as I think it's a right the
right relationship fit too I think you
have to get along with the people and
like you know the idea of what they're
doing um and to see how it fits you I
know you've spoken in the past that
people maybe don't know that that you're
half Korean but I also know that you
have started working with the
Asian-American Pacific Islander tennis
Association I have um what what work
have you been doing with them and why
has that been so important yeah so um
they asked me to be on the board like I
was almost a few years ago now and so
this year at the US Open we really
pushed to have an initiative there um as
far as an you know an Asian-American
Pacific Islander day that they did I
think during the second week there was
panels and talks and they did a couple
traditional um like Asian American
ceremonies uh for different different
types of things and I unfortunately was
playing so I couldn't really be a part
of it um I was thinking about being part
of something the second week but ended
up making second week and was busy
playing so I couldn't do anything yeah
but I guess they had a great turnout and
it was something really really special
and especially New York when there's a
really really big Asian-American
population and trying to get it out
there to families and have more kids
play tennis and stuff like that and I
think you know it was very successful
this year so that was the first thing
big thing kind of that they've done but
that was at the US Open so that was
really cool and I I guess it had a great
turnout and a really great response so
um yeah that was that was fun I wish I
could have you know done more but uh it
was it was nice and I yeah it was cool
on another issue uh you know I think a
lot of casual tennis fans maybe don't
realize that outside of the four majors
there's still a gender pay Gap in tennis
and I know it can be tough to get
women's matches televised in prime time
I know that's something that you've
spoken about in the past so how do you
feel the effort is going to change that
and you know what are your sort of
thoughts on the tennis landscape right
now yeah it's crazy time um you know
women's tennis is a huge sport for I
mean it's I think we're the highest paid
female athletes and it's a huge GL glal
sport but at the same time the yeah the
pay Gap is still very big and we always
talk about how it's equal at slams but
those are four tournaments a year it's
not equal at a lot of the other
tournaments our our season is very long
um you know 10 11 months practically and
yeah there's a here's a huge difference
that we're still working towards and I
think I think we need to do better at
marketing our game which hopefully I
think the WTA just started a new um
partnership with a private Equity
company that's going to come in and kind
of take the commercial side and
hopefully really revamp the marketing
and I think getting more stories out
there on all the incredible players that
we have um not just obviously in the US
but in the world and that's what's so
different is it's such an international
sport and there's so many different
stories and we reach so many people but
are we really telling those stories you
know the best way we can to the fans and
I think that's something that can really
grow and change and hopefully it will
next year and we'll start getting better
TV deals and and all of that but um yeah
we're trying to start you know the path
at least to equal prize money with some
circuit structure changes that are
starting next year and um hopefully we
see that payoff in the next few years
where we get more of these tournaments
at equal prize money we can make this
the last question so I'll make it a
tough one okay what do you want your
legacy to be
o I think as I've gotten older uh I
would love to just know that I helped
the game I think helped kids especially
I love tennis I love you know how much
much stronger and tougher it's made me
and I think it's created so many
opportunities even just sitting here
today the opportunities that it's
created for me it's it's insane so I
would just love for um my legacy to yeah
get to have kids understand that and get
them to play tennis and give them a
chance to have those opportunities and
then on top of that you know change the
game and hopefully leave a mark not just
results wise but you know whether it's
helping us get to equal pay or um
helping more kids get rockets in their
hands I think any of those things would
be amazing and yeah I guess you you
realize that you're it's bigger bigger
than yourself you know you want to leave
your your mark on the game and I think I
learned that reading a lot of Kobe
Bryant books so um he always said to to
keep giving back to the sport cuz if
you're not then it's kind of like what
are you doing so I I think I definitely
um felt that and I think think the same
way I want to you know give back to the
sport as much as I can well it's been
great having you with us Jessica and
want to wish you the best of luck the
rest of this season and Beyond thank
[Music]
you